I had an actor once do this to me I was
cracking a joke because he was being
inappropriate and everybody around me
was on my side because they always are I
just had some freaking veteran actor
actually a dick and uh and
I I said something and at one point he
went to me he put his hand up and he
went ah and I was like oh man did you
were you confrontational you just let it
go I was I was doing the thing where
someone's being inappropriate you crack
a joke to lighten the mood but the joke
is also pointing out the absurdity of
how the person's act yeah and by the
second joke that person caught on and
got frustrated I got frustrated with a
guy on Set uh Michael Ironside remember
him I know him well